what else you got nick damn chin you
were
oh oh here comes cat's ex-boyfriend
straight out of kuala lumpur prison
sorry we just had to include cat cat
hasn't said anything the entire time
it is early it ain't that early or not
hey it's pretty early cat do you know
anyone that looks like this guy or not
i know three people who looks exactly
like him yeah
i love this guy i love this guy too
she's like a nice
guy i got the big club also a qualifier
brendan who's comedy camp would you
rather be in gang gang buzz buzz
you started over please nick brennan was
interrupting everything hey guys i got
the big club
adam sandler or seth rogen who's comedy
camp would you rather be in
gang gang buzz buzz seems like a nice
fella
yeah wait we ain't did we do this before
not the crew there he's kind of taking
like like the crew
the rat pack like i'm going sandler i
think
i love sandlin yeah they're a little
older though
you know like the whole crew's a little
older yeah
at least seth rogen they're more of our
age yeah seth roger yeah
but like spades you know spade's super
close with sandler and you're close with
spades
spade's about yeah he's probably 50.
they're all they're all
they're all getting older that's true
who
who south brogan it's like what it's him
who else
um oh james jonah hill
yeah i don't know if that's his crew
though that's jonah hillis
him and jonah hillary and james franco
yeah that's the crew and then the
homeboy
in the back is our friend too the
canadian kid jay beerushall
yeah look at farley look at that picture
if you go nick down
right right there look how big farley
was god
damn damn look how big he was can we go
back to that next
gee your boy's thick
man that's crazy i've never seen him
that big
it's just the angle i don't think it is
though you can see look how his hand is
and that was
everything pretty fast yeah look at that
he's got the real
uh fat bastard double chin going on yeah
that's tough wow r.i.p
then chris rock just skinny as [ __ ] and
still skinny as [ __ ]
yeah yeah um i'm gonna go
it's such a tough question i'm gonna
stay out of both of them adam sandler's
crew's got way more money for sure
i'd rather be in my crew yeah our crew
is pretty cool
obviously not successful but different
you know
like they're crew they're older man i'm
not gonna really fit in with a bunch of
50 year olds
well brian's family
you're 47. yeah i'm 46.
you might fit him perfectly yeah yeah
maybe yeah you might be that young
little
that young little buddy the little that
little thotty
thick twink are you 37 right yeah
but you're gonna age man yeah it's
coming nothing you do try that donut dog
tell me what you think of it like a
fried wine you're gonna age
like that huh what are you doing i don't
like having it just in big pieces like
that
i like getting more of like a lozenge
you're just mangling it
it's like a suppository dude when i was
young they used to have suppositories
remember that
get your vitamins through your butt
praise god man
poof it yeah boof it dude what else you
got nick
we didn't answer we didn't answer
anybody well we both said we'd rather
not be in it we gotta just stick with
our crew
[Music]
is